DONALD TRUMP.
WHAT'S GOING ON IN THIS COUNTRY?
IS IT A REALIGNMENT OR SOMETHING
MORE?
GOOD EVENING AND WELCOME TO
TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT.
WE WANT TO START WITH JOEY REED.
YOU MAY NOT KNOW WHO SHE IS.
SHE'S AN ICON ON THE PROGRESSIVE
LEFT.
THERE IS NOT SINGLE FASHIONABLE
OPINION THAT SHE DOESN'T HAVE.
SHE'S A TOTAL START IN BROOKLYN.
BACK IN 2006, SHE SAID IT LIKE A
VERY DIFFERENT PERSON.
ON HER BLOG AT THE TIME, SHE
OPPOSED GAY MARRIAGE.
WHEN THE POSTS WERE DISCOVERED,
SHE HAD A COUPLE OF OPTIONS.
SHE COULD HAVE JUST APOLOGIZED.
PEOPLE CHANGE THEIR OPINIONS
OVER TIME AND GOOD FOR THEM, WHY
WOULDN'T THEY?
AMERICA HAS CHANGED, IS
CHANGING.
THE HONEST EXPLANATION WOULD BE
JUST FINE.
THAT'S NOT WHAT SHE DID.
SHE CLAIMED SHE NEVER WROTE
THOSE POSTS IN THE FIRST PLACE.
SINISTER AGENTS SOMEHOW BROKE
INTO HER BLOG RETROACTIVELY.
IT SOUNDS LIKE AN MSNBC SEGMENT.
PART OF WHAT THEY RUN EVERY
NIGHT.
SHE SAID IT WAS PART OF A
DISINFORMATION CAMPAIGN WAGED BY
SHADOWY FORCES.
THAT WAS HER EXPLANATION.
IT WAS A TOTAL CROCK AND WE KNOW
BECAUSE HER BLOG POSTS WERE
ARCHIVED BY OTHER WEBSITES
INCLUDING CONGRESS IN WASHINGTON
ALL THE WAY BACK TO 2006.
THAT MEANS IN ORDER FOR HER
CLAIMS TO BE TRUE, WHICH THEY
ARE NOT, THE SECRET HACKING PLOT
MUST HAVE BEGUN AT LEAST 12
YEARS AGO BEFORE ANYONE KNEW OR
CARED WHO JOY REID WAS.
THAT'S ALIVE, IT'S A CHILDISH
LIVE.
YOU WOULD HAVE TO BE A MORON TO
BELIEVE IT.
YET SHE'S TELLING IT.
HERE'S THE INTERESTING PART.
NBC NEWS IS ENDORSING ALL OF
THIS AS TRUE AND TRYING TO
CONVINCE OTHER PEOPLE IT'S TRUE.
YESTERDAY THE NETWORK OF
CIRCULATED A VAGUE REPORT BY AN
EXTREMELY ODD PERSON CALLED
JONATHAN NICHOLS WHO SAID HE IS
AN INDEPENDENT SECURITY
CONSULTANT IN WHICH HE AFFIRMS
HER LUDICROUS FANTASY.
OBVIOUSLY HE OFFERS NO EVIDENCE.
KEEP IN MIND THAT ED BC WHICH IS
PASSING THIS OUT TO OTHER NEWS
ORGANIZATIONS CLAIMS ITSELF TO
BE A NEWS ORGANIZATION.
NEWS ORGANIZATIONS ARE NOT
SUPPOSED TO LIVE.
THAT'S RULE ONE.
THAT NBC EXECUTIVES MAKE A HABIT
OF LYING.
THEY LIED ABOUT THE ACCESS
HOLLYWOOD TAPE A COUPLE OF YEARS
AGO.
THAT TAPE WAS LEAKED BY NBC TO
"THE WASHINGTON POST" ."
THE GOAL IN THAT LEAK WAS TO
HELP HILLARY CLINTON JUST TWO
DAYS BEFORE A PRESIDENTIAL
DEBATE AND IT HELPED.
NBC LATER PROMISED TO REVEAL HOW
THAT TAPE WAS LEAKED, BUT OF
COURSE WE HAVEN'T HEARD BECAUSE
THEY NEVER TOLD US.
THEY LIED.
YOU'RE STILL LYING ABOUT THAT.
NBC ALSO LIED WHEN IT RAN
INTERFERENCE FOR HARVEY
WEINSTEIN OVER A LONG PERIOD.
YOU REMEMBER THAT THE
INVESTIGATION INTO HARVEY
WEINSTEIN WAS KILLED.
HE HAD THE GOODS, GET NBC CLAIMS
THAT PHARAOH HADN'T NARROWED
DOWN THE STORY.
NBC SAID IT WASN'T READY YET,
ANOTHER LIE.
NOW NBC IS HELPING JOEY READ
LIFE ONCE AGAIN AND ALMOST
NOBODY ELSE IN THE MEDIA IS
SAYING ANYTHING ABOUT IT EXCEPT
MICHAEL BROWN.
HE IS A COLUMNIST AT
"THE BOSTON GLOBE" AND HE JOINS
US NOW TO TALK ABOUT WHAT'S
GOING ON.
I WENT TO BE COMPLETELY CLEAR.
I'M OKAY WITH PEOPLE CHANGING
THEIR VIEWS.
MY VIEWS ON ALMOST EVERYTHING
HAVE CHANGED.
I DON'T THINK THERE'S A SAYING
IN THAT.
WHY WOULD NBC ENDORSE AND RATIFY
AND DISSEMINATE WHAT IS IT SO
CLEARLY A FALSE EXPLANATION FROM
JOEY REED?
>> MAYBE THEY'RE JUST SUCKERS.
THEY FELL FOR THE RUSSIA GATE
STORY.
THERE'S -- THEY KNOW NOTHING
ABOUT HOW THE INTERNET WORKS
APPARENTLY.
I THINK WHAT HILLARY CLINTON
SAID SHE CLAIMED HER SERVER WITH
A CLOTH, THEY SAID OKAY, MAYBE
THAT'S IT.
YOU MAKE A VERY GOOD POINT.
THERE'S SOMETHING ODD ABOUT THE
WILLINGNESS OF NBC TO STANDBY A
STORY THAT IS SO LUDICROUS, IT
REMINDS ME OF A TIME IN THE PAST
WHEN ANOTHER NETWORK STOOD
BEHIND DAN RATHER AND WHEN
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" SAID THAT
BOGUS STORY WAS FAKE, BUT
ACCURATE.
WHAT'S HAPPENED, I THINK, IS
THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE IN THE
NEWS BUSINESS, BUT THEY'RE NOT
REALLY IN THE NEWS BUSINESS,
THERE IN THE POLITICAL ADVOCACY
BUSINESS AND JOY REID IS AN
AMAZING POLITICAL ADVOCATE.
SHE HAS A LOT OF FANS, SHE IS
VERY POWERFUL.
I WANT TO READ A TWEET, I DON'T
WANT TO GET THE WORDS WRONG.
THIS IS FROM A CLINTON STAFFER
WHO TWEETED OUT TODAY AND
UNBLOCKED ME, MAKE SURE YOU ARE
EVALUATING THIS SITUATION
THROUGH AN INTERSECTIONAL LENS.
SHE'S ONE OF THE MOST IMPORTANT
BLACK FEMALE VOICES ON TV.
THANKS.
SHE'S LYING.
OBVIOUSLY, NOBODY WINS IN A WAY
BACK MACHINE TO 2006 AND SAID
ONE DAY, I KNOW THIS PERSON WILL
BE ON CABLE TV.
IT'S NONSENSE.
IS IT REALLY SO BAD?
>> Tucker: THEY WENT TO THE
BOSS AND SAID LET'S MAKE A
PATENTLY LUDICROUS WHY THAT'S
UNTRUE.
THE BOSS WOULD SAY HOW ABOUT
NOT?
WHY NOT JUST SAY YOU DID IT,
ADMIT IT AND MOST FAIR-MINDED
PEOPLE WILL FORGIVE YOU AND MOVE
ON.
WHY WOULD NBC FURTHER POSTMERGER
ITSELF BY TYING ITSELF TO
SOMETHING SO OBVIOUSLY FALSE AND
STUPID?
>> BECAUSE THERE'S A HARD-CORE
GROUP OF PEOPLE WHO TUNE IN, SO
IT'S LIKE BONUS REVENUE AND THEY
ARE THERE ONCE AGAIN, NOT FOR
NEWS, THEY ARE THERE FOR THEIR
BIASES TO BE AFFIRMED.
MY TWITTER FEED TODAY WAS FULL
OF PEOPLE WHO SAID I AM GAY, I'M
LIBERAL, SHE HATES TRUMP.
SHE'S REALLY GOOD AT HITTING
TRUMP.
IF YOU HATE HIM ENOUGH, YOU CAN
DO WHATEVER YOU WANT AND ALL
SINS WILL BE FORGIVEN.
>> Tucker: TO PUT IT MILDLY,
SHE'S ATTACKED ME, I THINK SHE'S
OUR RACE BAITER, BUT I WOULD
HAVE GIVEN ANY HONEST PERSON A
PASS.
I SHOULDN'T TELL OUR VIEWERS,
"THE DAILY BEAST" WHICH IS AN
ONLINE BLOG HAS ANNOUNCED IT'S